splendide sur la terre encore je pense
que nous avons failli périr dans un
typhon genac
justement aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il ya
de particulier aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui que nous partons pour deux
mois et demi nous quittons la terre oh
la la c'est vrai j'avais oublié mais non
nous allons tourner sur paca luce notre
planète
peut-être me donne pas de fausse
information et c'est une des tracts ni
ma radio ni les ordinateurs oui c'est
vrai je sais au fait pourquoi tu touches
à la radio pour les plonger pour les
bons j'ai tué ponge les radios
maintenant oui après avoir renversé
montée j'étais bien obligés d'éponger il
faut économiser l'eau branding dans ma
radio
la doudoune se rend compte de ce que tu
fais non mais d'unité dans la loi de mes
forces je suis mais que vous passez nos
amis là ils vont rester sur une mauvaise
impression s'ils se souviennent de toi
comme d'un personnage grincheux raison
saison s'est pas cachée d'accord alors
souri et des gentils mort voir installé
à nouveau la terre ou revoir au revoir
amis de la terre bonnes vacances à tous
bonnes vacances et maintenant nous
partons pour une bonne vacances à nous
aussi merci au revoir au revoir au
revoir au revoir
bien sûr nous partons aller vite vite
vite manoeuvre au revoir ne vous
inquiétez pas un braquage notes ne sont
pas du tout parti pour deux